yes
okay
i'm so delighted to receive the words at
this research uh symposium for 2012 and
i'm really humbled and encouraged by
this recognition but really i can't
emphasize enough that i would achieve
nothing without my best mentors in
college their hard work dedication and
innovation are a pleasure to be part of
so it was a great opportunity now to
share i pay them within one minute my
experience if you can allow me for that
it's uh yeah during
okay during my research fellowship and
by tech i was so grateful to learn new
things every single day
stepping from diving into amex to
actively engage into real life research
and that was really amazing for me being
able to complete the work connecting the
dots inspired even by other ideas how to
improve myself
so with the current the problem is and
challenge is the seldens of omics study
that's available online and published
each year it's becoming more difficult
to wait through the sea of information
to achieve insights and make new
discoveries that will be the basics for
your future grants and projects and
that's why scientists even those who are
non-specialists need to have minimum
knowledge skills and tools to interpret
this eminent amount of data on what has
been done before understand how this is
related to your own data that would be
saving money and time so i'm supporting
those not only specialists in the
genetics or bioinformaticians to be
enrolled in this fellowship but also all
other specialities even clinicians even
and non-scientists because minimum
knowledge of these will upgrade your uh
your research activities so while my
primary research interest was oncology
to understand disease answer to response
progression i would like to pinpoint
that there was other opportunities to
learn other cross-omics domains like
metagenomics genomic infection as we say
as we said in these two days so it's
like a multidisciplinary opportunity in
a single part i've witnessed continuous
improvement in the content of the
courses during the last six months i get
this is
based on the continuous feedback of the
research fillers and i even learned from
the experience of other fellas in the
troubled shooting they faced through the
weekly uh research fellowship meeting
that was very fruitful so you have now
availability the courses the projects
the programs that is available in the
omics logics and the super pipeline had
the potential to accelerate our research
goals
from just discovery new target
identification validation to drug
repositioning to uh to cross over and
saving lives so at this end i would like
to thank everyone even those behind the
scenes like cinelika for supporting me
in the long journey and i'm i'm thankful
to my mentors who i kept sending a lot
of questions all the time day and night
and they kept replying back so thank you
so much for supporting me in this
learning journey and i hope everyone
else got enrolled soon and enjoyed this
experience like what i have passed
through thank you so much
thank you so much dr iman these are very
kind words and it feels good to hear
about the research fellows experience
that they could learn so much and gain a
lot from this program